All right, so here we are. First flip of
the episode and we sold a torture
ornament kit 15.4 mil. We bought it for
14.8. So nice 600k profit on that. So I
am going to bed now. As you can see, I
have a light ballista that has bought.
So I'm going to try to list that up for
3910.
Hopefully that'll sell on. If so, we
make 350k. And I'm going to try to buy
a,000
crystal keys. And if I get them in the
morning, I'll make a probably a separate
video on them. However, you'll also see
it in this one. And here we are in the
morning. As you can see, the loop and
two tabs have not bought at all.
However, the light ballistas have indeed
bought and one of them has sold. So, I
made 350k on that light ballista. This
obsidian cape, I was just seeing what
the margins were. I literally sold it
back for what I bought it for. Actually
9K less, but whatever. Um, as far as
what I'm going to do with these, I may
try to buy them for their actual prices
when I go to work next. However, I am
probably going to sell on these light
ballistas. Let me look up how much a
light ballista is selling for right now.
Um, just according to OS Buddy, I should
be able to sell these on for 389. Okay.
And oh, that is not right. And if I
would have sold them for that, I would
be pretty upset. So 389. Okay. If I am
able to sell those, that will mean I
will make
little about 1 mil if I'm able to sell
off all these light ballistas. So, I'm
going to try to get some new offers in
on these tooth and loop halves. And
other than that, maybe I'll buy some
more light ballistas. Not entirely sure
yet as to what I'm going to do with
them. All right. So, never mind about
putting the two halves together because
the tooth halves, both of them have one
up. And currently, I don't know how much
profit I'd be able to make off of it.
So, basically what I realized is if I
sell them on for the buy price of two
halves, I'm going to be able to make
about 1.4K on each of these, which means
I'll be able to make like what 350K
probably in total. So, I'd rather just
go with that. So, we're going to sell
them on for 340 and uh hopefully they'll
all sell maybe. So, instead of waiting
to sell them for 30.4, I actually
noticed that the price went up to 29.99
or 29K 9999 GP and figured I'd sell them
all for that. And they all instilled,
which is really nice. And considering I
bought them all for 1K less than that, I
made about 250k off of that. So, nothing
too shabby going on there. So, I believe
this is what we are going to leave in
while I go to work. Uh, third age mage
hat. Might be able to get a mill merch
on that. and light ballistas. I am fully
willing to buy these light ballistas at
3.3 mil when you consider that literally
a [__] monkey tail alone. Okay,
apparently 1 mil, but I swear to God
it's more than that. And that actively
traded price. This is what we are going
to leave our merches in for while I am
gone. All right, just got back from
work. As you can see, some of the U
seats have bought. We're going to get a
new offer in on that because there's
going to be a better price for it.
However, this third age mage hat has
bought. This is probably our biggest
item of this series so far. I'm going to
see what it's currently selling for. So,
it says that I should be able to sell a
third age mage hat. Well, actually, I
have no clue because I am the last
person to be able to buy this. So, I'm
going to list it up for 37
what? 680. We'll try that because that's
definitely under the actively traded
price and this thing barely gets bought
and sold each day. There's about two or
three every four hours. So, about one
every 1.5 hours. So hopefully this will
be able to sell and we'll make like a
one point or yeah about a 1 mil profit
in total which isn't bad at all. All
right, so there we go. Got all of the
you saplings done on my main account.
This is the one time that I do usually
transfer over things and stuff like
saplings. So going to list these up for
I believe that that was the price that
they were going to sell at which will
mean as I said earlier about 250k
profit. actually going to have to drop
him down to 10360, but it is what it is.
Hey, there we go. So, we made some
profit on the third age mage head. I
believe we made about 750kish.
So, that finally sold. I think I'm going
to get on to some other stuff. These
used saplings are going to have to sell
at some point, right? Like, I'm going to
lower the price just a little bit, but
to be honest, I want to make some money
off of this. More than likely about to
go to bed, but this has bought. We got
another torture ornament kit. It says I
should be able to sell it for 151.
Okay, I'm going to drop that down a GP.
But with that being said, I should be
able to make 600k off of that one merch.
Oh, actually 500k more or less. I don't
know why I put it in for that high of an
offer. I could have definitely had it
down. So, I'm going to throw this in
overnight. Somewhere around I think
probably 14.
You want to go 14165K
and we'll go with that. Well, right
before I went to bed, ended up selling
on the torture. So, as you can see,
cool. Uh, 500k profit, I do believe. All
right, it is the morning time. I don't
know why I said it like that, but I did.
Um, so we got another light ballista to
sell. All of our saplings have sold. So,
almost everything has sold that we need
to sell. The light ballistas I don't
think I made any money on to be honest
with you. I might have lost some in all
reality. However, these tor or
I tried to say torture and ornament. I
almost said tournament. Uh oh. I mean,
that makes sense, I guess. All right.
So, uh we're going to see what these
things sell on for. I'm a little
nervous. I bought them for 14.31.
And according to OS Buddy, the sell
price is currently 14.561.
And I'm not entirely sure if that's
correct, but I'll take it. I wouldn't be
too upset with that. All right. So,
we're going to do this. Look at this. uh
loop halves bought them all for
practically 9K. So we got those. Now
tooth halves on the other hand I am
going to put in an offer for 2980. We'll
see if those will buy. All right. So
there we go. All of the crystal keys
have been made. So we are going to go
ahead and buy one crystal key. Find out
the price. And that's [__] because I
just had some in for 41k and they
wouldn't buy. So, basically what I'm
going to do is just put them in for this
and they will sell eventually. Well,
just got back from going out to grab
some food with my mom. None of the
crystal seeds have sold, which is pretty
depressing because I'm not going to make
as much profit on these as I had
initially thought. Well, little time has
passed and all of the torch ornament
kits have sold. Still working on the
crystal keys. I'm going to undo this
offer for the light ballista, which
means we are up to 49 mil. pretty much
50 if you add this on. What are we at?
Let me do the math real quick. 612ish
I do believe. I do cuz that in total.
Yeah. 11. So yeah. Although I am still
going to put in an offer for some ring
of the gods because I do believe that I
can get them and I can get them for a
decent price. Hopefully,
and I say this very optimistically,
hopefully they do not drop on me. Do
plans. Change of plans. realized that
buying five of them may be a little
unrealistic. So, I'm going to put some
money into a 30-in full helm and see how
that goes for us. Now, I'm going to go
to work. So, uh hoping for the best. Not
really expecting a whole lot. I'm
expecting a little bit though. All
right, just came back from work. Um
third age full helm has bought all of
the crystal seeds finished selling and
not surprisingly really, the ring of the
gods did not buy. So, I'm going to
collect that. However, we got we got
this little guy to deal with. So, let's
find out the price of him real quick. We
had a torture ornament kit buy. I'm
going to try to sell this overnight.
We're going to try to go for 14130.
Okay. We'll make a cool 400kish on that
hopefully. Well, screw it. Um, ended up
selling before I went to bed, so that's
cool. I guess we made 140k off of a
third age item merch, which is pretty
disgusting, but at least we tried. Well,
even before I go to bed, one of these is
bought, which means I have the highest
buy offer in. So, I'm going to take both
of these out and drop it even lower
because if I can, I may as well. Logging
on in the morning and as you can see by
the chat log, my one torture ornament
has sold and another three have bought.
So, moment of truth. I'm going to check
the OS Buddy price on the website and it
says the buy price is 13.5, which is
good. that that's that's that's a good
sign because if that's right then that
means the buy price for these has gone
up
120k or in the least the sell price has
gone upund or at least the sell price
I'll still be able to make 120k. So one
way or the other I should be able to
profit a little bit off of these. I
could insta buy one and see what it buys
for but I think that's kind of a waste.
Oh, this uh this tournament kit has or
tournament kit. God damn it. I did it
again. This kit bought. None of the
other ones have sold. So, I'm just going
to lower the price on these by a little
bit. Maybe we can go what? 1348. Okay,
we'll make 100k on three of them and
then 400k on that one. So, we'll give it
a shot. All right, there we go. So, it's
taking a while today actually, but all
of these tournament or god [__] damn
it. Torture ornament kits have sold.
[__] All right. So, I found margins on
tormented bracelets. As you can see,
about a 100k realistically. So, I'm
going to go up and list. Actually, I
could get more because I didn't realize
I listed this below the buy price. So,
I'm going to put these up for $18170.
And once they sell, I'm going to try to
find a different price that I could get
them for. Pretty quickly, one of the
tormented bracelets has sold. So, I'm
going to try to buy another one. I think
I'm going to All right. What it was
tormented bracelet, right? Well, gave it
a little bit of time and our ballista
has sold. So, that's good. I guess we
got our money back on that one. I'm
probably going to buy or up my buy offer
maybe on the white ballistas. Maybe not.
Um, the tormented bracelet, however, on
the other hand, has sold one of them.
Um, this one I'm going to then go and
reby and hopefully this one can buy as
well. So, now we've made probably about
100k in total and now we're now we're in
the profit. Let's go. There we go. So, a
tormented bracelet has bought. So, we're
going to list this back up along with
the other one. I believe I can still
keep the price the same. I'm just going
to drop it 1k because I can and
hopefully that will make them sell
faster because if someone undercut me,
that's what I'm going to have to do
pretty quickly later. What the [__] am I
saying soon after I listed up these like
ballistas? They've all sold. So, going
to list up the next one that we've
gotten. So, it looks like we have the
highest buy and sell price in which is
really good. All right. So, based off of
the current OS Buddy price for torture
ornament kits, I should have had one of
them bought. So, here we go. Um, both of
the tormented bracelets have sold. The
torture ornament kit has bought, which
is good. Some of the two sold on our
bond did not do anything overnight,
which isn't necessarily surprising. It's
kind of annoying that the price of this
dropped, but it is what it is. I'm going
to list it up for about 3.1 and just go
ahead and lose like 90k on it because
it's not that big of a deal. Well, we
got something finally. So, old school
bond has been sold off. All right, screw
it. Um, so basically these things won't
sell for 30K. However, loop halfs I'm
sure we'll buy for somewhere around 9K
obviously because that's what they
always buy for 9011. That's fine with
me. We're going to buy some loot halves,
just make them into crystal keys, and
then we'll be able to make some profit
off of it because you might as well
since we already have them. Well, there
we go. Two more uh heavy blisses have
sold. Um I say two more. There's the
first two actually. But as you can see,
I'm making about 100k off of these. So,
I'm going to go back and buy a couple
more. The treasonous rings I should be
making about 50k off of, which isn't too
shabby at all. I forgot what [__]
price I'm getting these at. Holy [__]
did everything start to buy and sell.
So, pretty much these treasonous rings
apparently just aren't going to sell at
the price that it says they are. And I
just collected all of the [__] [__]
that I was going to talk over. All
right. So, these could be very uh well
known as far as an item to merch. So,
I'm going to check them out, see what
they buy and sell for. So, 1.57
and then I'm going to throw it up for
1.2 and see what the margin is on this.
So, as you can see, 170k. So, I am going
to try and buy and sell these. Hey,
there we go. One of the uh elder chaos
rogue tops have bought. So, we're going
to sell that back on. Make back the
money that we have lost. One of these
rogue tops sold and a treasonous ring.
I've come to the conclusion that I think
I got undercut on these elder rope tops,
which is a bit weird, but uh yeah, I'm
definitely just going to up my offer on
that. I believe it was 1407K.
Told you. Told you it [__] work.
There we go. 1407. Going to list it back
up 1575. So, uh make a lot of money off
that to be honest with you. It's about
170k merch, which is pretty insane for
something that's new like that. I mean,
it's it's understandable, but uh it's
definitely worth it. I don't know. I
didn't think that these things would be
that good. I forgot Elder Chaos robes
are actually 130. I didn't even notice
that whenever I bought them, but that's
insane as well. So, little update. I
ended up hitting my heavy ballista
limit, so I can't do any more of those.
I realized that the price has been
dropping, so I lower my offer by about
40k to sell them. I think I also hit my
treasonous ring offer, so I'm going to
cancel that out. As you can see, our
elder top, we had one buy and uh one has
sold so far. and two of the uh of the
robes have sold. So, I got some buy
offers in right now. We're at 40 mil and
uh you know, just hanging out trying to
make some money off of these. I might do
some torture ornament kits cuz those are
always really good. There we go. So, two
more of these elder
tops have bought and three more of the
bottoms have bought. Well, we ended up
being able to sell one of both of these,
which still means I have the buy or the
highest sell offer in. So, I ended up
buying another one. And as you can see,
I am going to be listed up for 1530K, I
do believe, is what the other one is
going for. Yeah, was able to buy two
more Elder Tops for 1.407. Going to sell
them on obviously again for 1530K. Hey,
now I know I can buy them for uh
cheaper. I could have saved myself about
80K. So 1365 is a new buy price. I'm
going to lower this to 1525 just in
case. Well, here we go. I'm about to go
to work. So, I'm going to just clean up
basically what I have in the trade
screen so far. So, I'm going to sell off
this for 1528K as well. Take out my
offer for the Elder Chaos robes because
they're probably going to drop to be
honest. So, I don't want to have a buy
offer in these torture ornament kits. I
have the highest buy price in right now.
However, if they go down while I'm at
work, I'll be a little upset. So, I
think I'm going to Where the hell is it?
Where is it? All right. Give me a
second. [__] There. There it is. All
right. So, I think I'm going to leave it
an offer for like 1278K
and I'll buy two. I don't want to buy
too many of them. And then light
ballistas. None were or I bought this
one, tried to find the margins and sell
it on for 3 mil and it did not sell. So,
I'm going to buy out as many light
ballistas as I can for 3 mil and try to
sell this one for 3.2. And we'll see how
that goes whenever I get back from work.
All right. So, problem. Um, these Elder
Chaos Druid tops did not sell. I do not
know the price. So, I have to go ahead
and buy one myself. 1377, which means I
will be able to sell these for even a
40k profit still, which isn't too bad,
and I am happy with that cuz I thought I
could have lost a lot more on them.
However, we also have a torture ornament
kit and five light ballistas. So, we're
going to check out the prices of light
ballistas and ornament kits, and then we
will be back in a second. I'm going to
throw in an offer for 327K
and we can see if that buys and I
believe it will. It did for 31850. So,
we're going to sell them on for that.
3185K. I don't know why I said the O at
the end. So, we're going to sell them on
for that, which means off of the five
that we bought, we'll be making about
180K per one. And it's currently saying
the buy price is 11700,
which sucks.
Well, um about that. So, we're going to
just, you know, try to try to list it up
for
that's I don't know what to do. They
shouldn't have really dropped. I think
they'll honestly go back up possibly.
So, I'm just going to go 124 to5 and
we'll try to sell them on for that. All
right, so there we go. Woke up in the
morning and as you can see, all the
light ballistas have sold along with the
elder chaos tops which I made about 150k
on each of them. Ballistas I probably
made about 160k on each of them.
However, the torch ornament kits have
not sold and their price has dropped
about a mill since I bought them, which
is really [__] annoying. And uh yeah,
we're going to leave it at that. They
dropped to 10.8 mil overnight and they
started to go back up. I honestly think
that they're going to continue to go
back up. I think they've hit their
lowest point. And I mean, it really
doesn't make sense for them to drop more
than a fury was ever dropped to a fury
ornament kit because this one is the
upgraded like amulet kit and is probably
more rare, I would imagine. Now, I'm
heading to work. We're going to leave
all this stuff in the torch ornament
kits. I will even hold on to. As you can
see, I'm buying another one right now
because I think I I think that they've
hit their low and I will spend a few
days holding on to these. I really do
not care one way or the other. Logging
on to the merch account after work and
hoping that some stuff Oh my goodness.
All right, so we bought a lot of stuff,
sold a lot of stuff. So, as you can see,
the torch ornament kits have sold. I'm
going to see what the torture kits are
currently. Torture kits are currently
buying for 11 mil and selling for 11.66.
So, we can merge those maybe a little
bit. However, we did do a good job in
being able to sell these for 11.99. So,
good work on that. All the crystal seeds
have sold or crystal keys, my bad. Um,
all the light ballistas have bought and
as I can tell from OS Buddy, it says I
should be able to sell these light
ballistas on for this price, which would
mean if I can, I bought Oh my, are you
kidding? I sold them all instantly. Uh,
that's annoying. But, uh, as you can
see, I bought them all for 15.2 and was
able to sell them all for 17.2. So
that's a 2 mil profit, instant 2 mil
profit. Then the torch ornament kit that
we were able to buy for 10.25, we should
be able to sell for 11.5. And all of
these rubies have bought for 13 or
1308k. So I'm going to go buy a ruby and
see what I can sell these on for now. So
rubies currently are selling for 1340.
However, I'm going to throw these in
overnight and just try to sell them for
1375.
All right, morning time, ladies and
gentlemen. So, we're going to end off
this video unveiling what uh what's
currently going down in the GE. So,
let's find out. And we were able to buy
all these Elder Chaos Tops, buy two Ring
of the Gods, and sold the torture kit.
So, we weren't able to sell the rubies.
That's fine. I'm still going to make
profit on those. The torture ornament
kit sold for 115, which means we made
Let's see it. Which means we made What
the [__] Where is it? Okay, so we made
1.2 2 mil on the torture kit, which is
sick. Um, bought two Ring of the Gods
for 10.8. I want to see what I'm going
to be able to sell them for, so give me
a second.
All right, so according to OSBody, they
dropped overnight to exactly what I put
my price in for. However, I think and I
think I'm going to be able to sell them
for this price. Okay, well, that was a
lot of lag, but nonetheless, I'm going
to try to sell them for 11.3. And if
they do sell for 11.3, make we make
ourselves 800k on that. And some Elder
Chaos Rogue Tops were uh about 1.3 mil
last night, and I put in a low ball
offer, so hopefully they didn't just
drop a ton on me.
Uh it looked like they actually did drop
a lot overnight, but they did not drop
below what my offer was. So, I'm going
to buy one and whatever price we were
able to buy it for, I will then go on
and sell it for that. So 113
or 1133k.
So I'm going to go for 1132k because I
approve of undercutting on high price
items. So as you can see there, we're
going to make about 80k off each one of
those, which is a 400k merch if they all
sell. And the rubies we're just going to
lower the price on. And light ballistas.
I really honestly have no clue what's
going down with them. Uh damn, rubies
dropped. I could have sold them
overnight for a little less and I would
have made more money, man. Okay, but
whatever. We'll make 12 GP off each one,
which means we'll make 100K. I don't I
don't care. Whatever. We'll go with it.
Unless that's H. That's actually the med
price. Oh [__] they dropped a ton. All
right, whatever. We're going to sell it
for that then. All right, so
nonetheless, that will be it for this
video. Um, merches for episode 10 are
done. I think from now on every time I
hit a like an episode 10, I'm going to
do like a little montage of like the
best merches going after that, just like
a little review. Um, if you guys like
that idea, feel free to let me know down
below. And nonetheless, I think that'll
be it for today. So, if you guys enjoy
the video, feel free to leave a like. If
you guys have anything you want me to
improve upon or anything you want to say
to me, leave that in the comment section
down below. And if you want to see more
in the future, hit that sub button.
Nonetheless, hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace.
Listen
to me.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat.